i think i probably would have been about
eight years old i think that's when the
first one came out it became like our
family thing
emma roberts is breaking her silence on
that emma watson photo mix-up during the
harry potter reunion special let's
rewind a bit that's emma watson during
the hbo max reunion special harry potter
20th anniversary returned to hogwarts
reflecting on when she was first cast as
hermione granger and this photo of a
little girl wearing large minnie mouse
ears flashes on screen but turns out
that isn't watson it's another famous
emma emma roberts
um fans will recall the photo was posted
by roberts on instagram back in 2012
easy mistake by the producers right yeah
definitely well on wednesday the british
actress got in on the fun and shared the
adorable photo of roberts to her
instagram account jokingly writing i was
not this cute emma roberts hashtag emma
sisters forever and a few hours later
roberts responded by reposting the image
and showing her fellow emma some love
writing ha ha i don't believe that i
couldn't really pretend
that it wasn't going to be a big deal
but this is not the first time the
scream queen star has been a big topic
on social media last summer this video
she posted went viral
[Music]
social media users were so into the
video they took it a step further and
created their own memes like this one
that says me trying to get the barista
at pret to give me my coffee for free
emma saw the memes all over and poked
fun by creating one herself me going
viral after 30. thank you gays and
whoever else it's surreal it's so fun
when the actress isn't busy being a hot
topic on social media she's a proud mama
the american horror story star welcomed
her son rhodes with her partner garrett
headland back in december 2020 and when
eatsy caught up with the actor shortly
after becoming a dad he gushed all about
parenthood every day is a blessing i
like to call this period the precious
delirium
and you know everybody says
appreciate it
um
soak it up goes by so fast so you know
i'm really taking that advice and then
really trying to wallow in it yeah it's
really remarkable like
i smile from from coast to coast all day
[Music]
long you